undateable I watched the show very loose
it's probably the loosest show I've seen
on television yeah and you guys it's
live you guys do not you just seem to do
whatever you want yeah that program in a
way that people I think fine for you but
sometimes I noticed that you guys are
tweeting and sending out Instagram shots
while the show is going on live yeah and
I can see you guys like you don't have a
line but someone out you know someone
else is talking giving a speech and
someone's just tweeting so yeah we're
out of focus in the background like this
yeah like shooting people well whatever
irresponsible yeah definitely but we're
we're all for comedians on the show and
like you know we're we're not trying to
reinvent the wheel it's just it's not
we're making Breaking Bad do you know
what I mean like if Omar very much like
if Omar from the wire was tweeting while
he was acting that wouldn't work out but
for us it's like whatever you know what
I mean yeah it's a responsible but like
look at the way I dress today do you not
I mean that's true you know
you um close your legs
[Applause]
close those up good
the time what is this
[Applause]
my testicles oh hey my motto is what
will Bon Jovi do yeah is that bad people
always say sit up like my mom but I
don't do that
[Applause]